c'est non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les messieurs parilla
avec vanille 202 le monde à nous nous en
faisons le serment avant de passer à
table
pas question de lui fort pas rien sortir
y arriverez le maire mais avant delhi
[Applaudissements]
l'audience est reprise je vous rappelle
que nous jugeons aujourd'hui jean
constantin qui est inculpé de cruauté
envers les animaux et plus précisément
vers les lépidoptères les autruches pour
avoir écrit jolie fleur de papillons et
mon truc en plumes et qu'il est inculpé
en outre ça n'a rien à voir et votre
physique d'injures au jeu le permettre
je me le permettre d'agir au patrimoine
national car il s'est moqué de paul
claudel l'auteur du soulier de satin en
chantant les pantoufles et puis enfin d'
atteinte au moral de l'armée en chantant
waterloo une défaite française ne vont
pas lieu d'être fiers oui mais c'est
quand même opposé pas revenir là-dessus
mais si on recommence ou pas la balle a
pas ce que je vous dit tout à l'heure je
m'appelle pu bien mais le même chose
vous célébrez les défaites et jamais les
victoires ben c'est à dire que je
pensais toujours provisoire une défaite
ah bon en revanche à en plus ah oui mais
c'est bien la société justement poseur
de mon père ça voilà la société
justement va se venger maintenant c'est
la revanche de la société que vous allez
maintenant entendre par l'organe
puissant et pas très généreux du
procureur général de la république des
proches française
oui
[Musique]
merci de l'autre jour c'est très beau
françaises français belges belle
monsieur le président mon chien monsieur
l'avocat le plus badinter
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour je m'en doutais le
mauvais esprit qui vous anime
vous monsieur le président vous le livre
y poser sur un bavoir foule était moins
pourri d'office vous l'experte en
papouilles psychosomatiques est encore
plus vous le pianiste des îles le
mauvais esprit qui vous anime vous a
tout naturellement guidé à ne voir en
l'accusé jean constantin que le grossier
démoralisateur des troupes qui se
gaussent de waterloo ricane sur les
tombes des cocus de verdun des poilus de
verdun et exhibe sans vergogne son
mépris pour napoléon le chah d'iran et
le thon à l'huile
et bien sûr comme par hasard vous avez
pratiquement passé sous silence l'autre
crime le vrai crime de jean constantin
qui est que cet homme n'est pas un vrai
blanc comme moi qui suis de souche
périgourdine par mon père alsacienne par
ma mère et cgt par le facteur qui peut
toujours se brosser cette année pour les
étrennes parce que leur grève à la con
ça commence à bien faire
jean constantin mesdames et messieurs
les jurés est un métis avec 1m minuscule
parce que si on les remet une majuscule
deviennent arrogants
[Applaudissements]
le dossier de jean constantin à cet
égard est accablant son père et brésil
aux communistes
sa mère et suissesses donc d'origine
gréco romaine comme tous les vrais blanc
de type germaneau scandinave
hélas le laxisme qui règne en europe et
dans le monde depuis la victoire de la
populace en 1789 fait que seuls
maintenant l'afrique du sud reste
aujourd'hui un pays vivable pour les
gens normaux n'ont métissée mais ce
silence les [ __ ] mais savons-nous
vraiment mesdames et messieurs les jurés
qui sont les sud africains qu'est ce que
la sud africaine
[Applaudissements]
est ce vraiment ce pays de haine que
nous décrivent complaisamment les anti
raciste primaire viscéraux attention ne
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit je n'ai rien contre les anti
racistes
moi même je ne suis pas raciste certes
je ne donnerai pas ma fille est un [ __ ]
mais je le donnerais encore moins mon
[ __ ] à ma fille parce que c'est moi qui
l'ait vu le premier il n'y a pas de
raison
la sud-africains les sud-africains sont
appelés ainsi pour que nous ne les
confonds pas avec les nord africains
qui en ont seulement qui ont non
seulement le type nord africain mais la
gonzesse aussi la sud-africaine qui
s'étend sans vergogne sur plus d'un
million de kilomètres plus ou moins
carré est peuplé de 24 millions
d'habitants qui sont pour la plupart
extrêmement vulgaire sauf les blancs
cette population se décompose de la
façon suivante 70% de banc tout 17 %
d'européens 29% de métis 14%
d'asiatiques et 18 % sans opinion
c'est énorme les bantous sont appelés
ainsi en hommage au coureur cycliste
sénégalais banques la jolie dont l'
homosexualité latente étaient notoires
et qui remporta à paris nantes en 1933
en chantant quand je pense à fernande
the band la ségrégation
hop
la ségrégation en sud africain tous les
européens pratiquent la ségrégation
apartheid la ségrégation consiste de la
part des blancs à respecter la
spécificité des [ __ ] en n'allant pas
bouffer chez eux au reste la cuisine
bantous est tout à fait exécrable tant
sur plan de l'hygiène alimentaire dans
les blancs sont très friands en revanche
que sur le plan du décor de la table qui
laisse à désirer c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
par exemple ces gens-là met la
fourchette à droite au couteau à gauche
ça y est je les dis la cuisine
il me revient d'avoir été conviés à la
table d'un sorcier bantou avec lequel
mon épouse était très lié malgré la
tradition ségrégationniste pour des
raisons d'affinité inhérentes l'énormité
de la zigounette de ce sauvage et bien
c'était très mauvais leur plat national
est la biche aux abois mail basse et
dégueulasse enfin c'est dégueulasse
la télévision sud africaine la
télévision sud africaine est l'une des
plus passionnantes du monde mesdames et
messieurs non seulement il n'ya jamais
des missions avec giscard mais il y en a
pas non plus avec mitterrand enfin les
villes les plus connus de la sud
africaine sont johannesburg le cap
pretoria et durban les villes les moins
connus son poste hearst rom version
scanning
big bang est amazigh mais on voit bien
on voit bien mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le président à la lumière de
cet exposé que jean constantin est
coupable d'ailleurs tous les étrangers
sont coupables je les ai
j'enrage jean désespoir jean vieillesse
ennemie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma haine des étrangers date de l'époque
où je fis mes débuts dans un quotidien
parisien phagocyter depuis par un
plésiosaure monopolistique avant de
percevoir clairement l'éventail infinie
de mes possibilités journalistique qui
devait m'amener par la suite des chiens
écrasés au chat noyer puis à la
télévision qui montera à la france
entière quel beau visage de prince
pirates se cachait derrière la plume du
canard c'est pas une partouze de
palmipèdes c'est une licence poétique de
quoi je parlais ah oui avant avant tout
ça c'est dur vous allez voir j'ai été le
[ __ ] d'un écrivain juif sur la sphère
benbarka rendez-vous pour l'horreur
l'horreur alors qu'en réalité j'étais
doué pour assurer les rubriques
sportives si cher à votre coeur jean
constantin j'ai encore en tête le
premier titre de mon premier article
sportif c'était au lendemain de la
demi-finale de roland-garros sur six
colonnes j'avais titre et premier
nastase le 6 2e vilas le cap
en fait j'étais parti à la fin du
premier round avant la mi temps
remarquez je me suis rattrapé à la radio
l'année dernière à wimbledon c'était oui
bien si pierre desproges qui vous parle
en direct de wimbledon au début du
premier set c'est mcenroe qui sait
mcenroe qui passe à connor ce qui passe
à mcenroe qui passe à connor ce qui
passe à je crois que c'est un mcenroe
qui passe à la fin j'ai fais un malheur
[Applaudissements]
en fait aujourd'hui avec le recul
nécessaire le recul est toujours
nécessaire
comme le soulignait magnifiquement louis
aragon dans sa fameuse lettre staline à
brest 9 chaire leonid il faut
déstabiliser notre parti il faut que tu
fasses toi aussi ce grand pas en avant
car si j'avance et que toi tu recules 7h
à 10h avec avec le recul nécessaire
dis-je il m'apparaît un peu tard que je
n'aurais jamais dû quitter la rubrique
des chiens écrasés j excellait le mot
n'était pas trop fort je peux bien
l'avouer aujourd'hui sans fausse
modestie pour alimenter jour après jour
ma rubrique des chiens écrasés quoi
qu'il arrive il m'arrivait d'écraser les
chiens moi même par la suite j'ai changé
de journal là on m'a confié la rubrique
des enfants martyrs
j'en ris encore
un jour on m'envoie avec un photographe
crise un couple de brut qui défonçaient
leurs mômes de 7 ans à coups de pelle à
charbon et l'acier est périodiquement
sur le poêle pas méchamment comme ça
pour tuer le temps en attendant
l'ouverture du gérant nicolas quand nous
arrivons sur les lieux le père et la
mère sont déjà en cabane l'enfant est là
sur les genoux d'une voisine qui le
couvrent de caresses et de bonbons là je
m'arrête tout de suite parce que je vais
vous dire une chose une confidence c'est
une histoire vraie l'enfant donc hélas
sur les genoux d'une voisine qui le
couvrent de caresser de bonbons c'est
sans doute son premier jour de joie
depuis sa naissance à ce petit vous
savez comment sont les enfants futile et
où il oublie alors celui ci sourit
franchement largement complètement
seulement moi en fait c'est pas moi qui
est arrivé mais c'est vrai seulement moi
j'étais très ennuyé pour la photo là
encore il faut me comprendre avant de
venir faire leurs reportages
j'avais déjà envoyé mon titre au marbre
enfants martyrs de points en larmes et
défiguré pierrot c'est en hurlant de
douleur va voir page 3 alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour la photo vous demande le
photographe parce qu'il n'est pas en
larmes il hurle pas de douleur et en
plus il est même pas défigurer ça va
être très mauvais en effet les parents
indignes avait pris soin par un souci de
notre habilité bien compréhensible de ne
pas abîmer le visage du gamin certes
nous aurions pu le photographier les
fesses mais une photo de fès à la une
d'un journal respectable vous n'y pensez
pas c'est un journal pas vulgaire alors
que faire pour que cette tête d'ange
ronronnant de plaisir justifie mon titre
aubade il photographie accueille casser
la gueule
je vois pas d'autre solution
et joignant le geste à la parole il
envoya une gifle gamin grâce à quoi la
france profonde pu dès le lendemain
s'émouvoir sur les enfants martyrs cette
histoire est seulement à moitié faux ce
jeu tient vachement à le souligner ce
journaliste c'était pas moi mais si
jamais un pochard septuagénaire semi
grabataire et confident la suisse cassis
s'effondre en pleurant près de vous sur
le zinc d'un bistrot de la rue
montmartre en vous racontant qu'il a
fait ça lui ne le croyez pas comme dit
ma concierge
il raconte n'importe quoi ces
journalistes
donc jean constantin est coupable mais
son avocat vous en convaincra mieux que
moi c'est non
[Musique]